foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the daily live nerdy news show talking
about everything we want to be talking
about and today damn it Janet uh we are
um coming to you live from the new
rockstars headquarters and uh nothing
else special going on about this episode
I don't think so I think that's the most
enthusiastic Brad
we're of course I'll dress like cast
members of The Rocky Horror Picture Show
we'll get to that in a moment uh but
also in this episode oh I'm I'm Zach
Huddleston join with me uh we've got uh
Riff Raff Barrick
uh Dr uh Jessica clemenfurter and uh
Tommy he's a tender subject
hi everyone
hello
great to be here keep it grouchy to
mouchy whoa okay we're mixing it up
today of course on this episode we're
going to be talking we're still
processing uh all the repercussions of
uh that were kind of forever trailer
yesterday we're gonna be talking about
Dr Doom and how he could be introduced
in this film we've also got we're going
to be talking about Chris Evans maybe
returning to the MCU uh Deadpool and
Hugh Jackman Written in the Stars
Ant-Man 3 trailer baby
and uh we will be doing the time warp uh
presumptively for every 100 in super
chats uh we will bust into a spontaneous
time warp dance right yes uh and I'm
from 2002. I was born that year yeah I
don't know what a lot of our a lot of
our gen Z viewers are just like what are
they dressed up like Roblox characters I
haven't purchased yet or what's going on
here
uh yeah we're dresses fortnite skins
okay and then for every hundred dollars
we're gonna emote the time warp is that
okay simps
is that is that cool no cash get it now
100 bucks and we dance
it's a dangy meatloaf today
um oh and also we just want to pre-plug
this Friday werewolf By Night comes out
that episode of the break room on Friday
is gonna be a very special werewolf by
night-themed episode we've already got a
lot of cool stuff planned yeah Tommy's
gonna be pulling out all the stops
um so watch the show yeah make sure you
make sure you watch it's only an hour
long guys it's not a full-length movie
you don't have to be like out of time
stay I'm staying up at midnight because
I don't I want to get ahead of it
Zeitgeist you know what I mean I want to
be really into it live tweeting and also
if you guys have cool werewolf cosplays
that you've done over here send them to
us tag me uh at Tommy Beckle on Twitter
tag and our break room and we'll put
some of them up on the show a werewolf
in 2005. well Jessica then you can be on
the break room on Friday
maybe maybe if you're just like a here
suit Mediterranean fella yeah you want
to show us those hairy chests go ahead
and send those to Lulu Clemens okay
that's got hamburger meat all right no
no no no no no no no uh if you are a
werewolf you can just send a picture of
yourself say it's a costume no we won't
tell you yeah there's no full moon on
Friday you're safe
um but let's get into some headlines
super chats are flying people are really
excited to watch us dance okay well
they're mad they're like are they going
to be singing and it's like yes or
singing and dancing yeah singing 49ers
own the bills Drake bread what are you
drunk they're not even the same okay
Tommy don't don't give those comments
the time of day uh
uh the headlines yes uh so we get some
news today now this movie had been
announced previously
um El muerto this is in the spumcy the
uh Sony spider Universe of films like
craving the Hunter and Madam Webb uh we
knew Bad Bunny was on board to play El
muerto the character and now a director
has been hired yes uh
Jonas cuarone who is the son of Alfonso
Caron who's done gravity and Birdman a
bunch of other big fancy movies
um and also there's a writer hired uh
I'm not going to be able to pronounce
his name very well Gareth kunit El
cosier
apologies to you Gareth I think I got
that part of your name correct but um
he's also the person doing the Blue
Beetle he's writing script yeah he's
right
he's right he's running that way evil
blue writing or writing writing oh right
writing she's writing the Blue Beetle
why would that qualify him
I don't know you know I said better
myself for director of el Alberto and
it's you know it's messed up that a
director's son gets to do it yeah okay
they're probably got as much as a gift
as Alfonso did and so it's probably I
mean I would have done a good job that's
only a second okay sure I mean it's a
big first step for your first film
directing to be you know I'm good
friends with Benito that's what I call
him oh Bad Bunny yeah I think it was
also I think it's a good reach because
they're probably also looking for uh any
latinx like performer or like anybody
that can contribute and I feel like
that's probably a good way to go that's
probably a good and bad buddy probably
was like here's the part here's the
problem and people pointed out that that
screenwriter who's doing the um Blue
Beetle film that will be the first
latinx starring superhero movie this
might be the second the dude so far
doing 100 of the latinx movies yeah
for him
um in other superhero news Anthony
Mackey did an interview where he said
it's doubtful Chris Evans will ever come
back to the MCU I mean does it mean 100
uh but he had this fun quote where he's
like Chris is so far gone from Marvel
like Marvel's not even in his radius
he's so far gone he's enjoying life he's
like an old retired dude taunting him oh
yeah he's taunting him out of retirement
he does sound like some underhanded digs
this is how they got Tom Brady back and
now his whole marriage is falling apart
I mean could this also be smoke screen
maybe Anthony Mackey knows he's coming
back
uh and he just wants to throw people off
the set I don't know uh but also yeah
enjoy your life Chris Evans you gave us
enough time as cap I mean yeah go do
green man forever or yeah gray man too
great man too great man rises The Gray
Man cometh beige man even grayer uh man
in um in other news uh Deadpool Creator
Rob leefeld who he created the comic uh
Deadpool told Disney
um that he needed to Jackman he did an
interview with comicbook.com he's
talking to Brandon Davis over there and
he said I had a meeting with Disney and
they were picking my brain about what I
wanted and I'm so happy that I have that
email because I followed it up saying
I'm gonna put this in writing and look
look what everybody wants is Hugh as
Wolverine and Ryan is Deadpool that's it
this could be as big as end game throw
it in the chat will Deadpool 3 be as big
as end game confirm
what what does Rob believefield have to
do with it I don't know oh well he'll be
referenced in the movie Once by Ryan
Reynolds so that's probably true yeah
well and is this the way too if Rob
lefield just to like he had a general
meeting with Disney he mentioned that
they should try to get Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine and now he's taking credit for
it happening well you know we know he's
not gonna be Hands-On or put his foot to
the pedal that's for sure Rob leefield
famously could not draw feet but
um
he can't drop Pockets lots and lots lots
of cargo Pockets uh talented artist uh
okay
talking about Black Panther wakanda
forever Ryan coogler uh has this I love
this quote he was talking about Neymar's
look in the film and he said I think uh
with making these types of movies you've
got to lean into the weird stuff or you
risk missing what makes it fun he's got
really unique features and things that
don't necessarily go together he can
breathe underwater obviously but he's
got those little wings on his ankles
he's got pointy ears and walks around in
his underwear it's all fun man I mean
absolutely right yeah totally right I
mean we saw in the 2000s those extra
movies which are great and they're fun
to go back to but they're all just
wearing generic black leathers and it
was like well what if superheroes were
in the real world and and Blended in and
were stylish and it's like no it's more
fun if you have these high concept ideas
like yeah they why not have wings there
is no grounded right name or the
Submariner right like there's no way to
realistically do a character that lives
underwater right so it's like you might
as well have a ton of I thought the
gritty SpongeBob reboot was pretty good
but he killed Patrick
he gave him some tainted cocaine I
didn't appreciate the lovemaking scenes
in that movie it was too much SpongeBob
and Sandy yeah so there's too much for
me she was Sandy all right will we be
doing a bootleg breakdown of this chick
yeah don't worry guys I got it okay uh
oh uh Ant-Man uh quantumania producer
Brian Gay hinted at a trailer release
which you know the last couple Marvel
movies usually right before a Marvel
film comes out we get the trailer for
the next one right like the first what
kind of forever trailer came out around
the time of uh love and thunder right so
maybe as we are approaching wakanda
forever and we're getting close to the
Ant-Man uh quantumania trailer which is
the next Marvel film and so this
producer was saying we were able to show
some things at d23 and we'll have more
coming in the fall and of course ahead
of the premiere early next year now fall
denotes what months
so I mean we're in the middle of fall
right now so you didn't say winner he's
gonna fall yeah I feel like it's also
kind of been leaking out a little bit
online uh people who recorded it at d23
uh if they were able to they keep kind
of keep leaking out and that happened
too with Comic-Con I don't know if
that'll like force Disney's hand uh if
someone like hacked into the servers and
released an unfinished version that was
like a little cleaner maybe but I bet
they'll put it out soon well and the
trailer will have a lot more in theory
than just the footage that was shown
right at d23 or Comic-Con right yeah
yeah we'll feel more finished maybe have
more yeah they might change it up a
little bit yeah I have more effects in
it it also I mean they could put it in
front of black panther right like they
could debut it with the film coming out
if they wanted to but I don't know we'll
probably see if we're getting
dangerously close to having to do the
time warp on screen folks oh Brian K
you're pushing us to the precipice can I
see your left hand my left hand yeah
does your shirt have your initials on it
it does this is a monogram shirt wow oh
my God
they're not a sponsor this way oh no
then screw them
I'm wearing Jackie's khakis tomorrow
I wish I could have got some Zacky guy
how did I get a pairs
you know this this was free the the
place I got this shirt monogram you're
sure did you have to bring the shirt no
no I ordered it online anyways and
there's a funny thing the size there's a
funny thing monogrammed into the inside
of this collar
um that is not my initials but is a
phrase anyways um afterwards uh Emma
Caulfield Ford sure might not be a um
household name but she played Dottie in
one division the blonde woman that was
kind of the lead
um uh Stepford wife kind of character is
she related to Henry Ford
but she uh confirmed that she's gonna
return in Agatha coven of chaos the
upcoming uh series which is interesting
because like there was not like a
dangling thread there at the end of the
series for her character seemingly she
was just a townsperson in New Jersey
that had been brainwashed inside of the
hex so it's interesting that she will
return in this series yeah I like it
though a little continuity a little
through line
I got a bad feeling the music
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just a jump to the left
[Music]
the right put your hands on your hips
[Music]
all right no more of that
yes uh daddy she was one I remember
early on in the show when we were doing
lots of theorizing uh we were like
what's up with daddy she seems to know
something or she's very mysterious is
the scene where the glass breaks up yeah
she was one of the early ones that was
kind of breaking out of the hex a little
bit I think she like confronts wand at
some point right doesn't like she say
something to her yes uh I forgot I have
to go we watch the whole series but yeah
it would be interesting to see her come
back and it probably means that we're
gonna see some version of West View as
it is now unless it's a flashback or
something but well and you pointed out
Brandon right I think that she's
credited differently and like that was
John sorry producer John pointed out and
I think the last episode of the show
she's not credited his daddy she's
credit credited as um Dottie Proctor
yeah she's a woman that she came back to
become Sarah Oh from um
right that name is promise with like
Salem and like the witch trials and
stuff but he Proctor so maybe we find
out kind of you know uh Agatha was a
conscious participant in the hacks right
she was awake kind of maybe there were
other witches there that were subdued by
the hex because Wanda's magic was so
powerful or something like that or it
could be the it could be like the New
Salem and it's like why they're coming
to New Jersey it's like this is our new
Salem oh yeah we get more power here
maybe and that could be reason why Wanda
is like was able to take over the entire
city quicker than like any other
probably for other place and she could
have probably taken over a different
place bigger but it's like we only saw
New Jersey so maybe more power to that
small who would want to live in New
Jersey
it's a Garden State it's beautiful
um go see the Devils the hockey team or
just go a few hours North to New York a
Superior State that uses New Jersey as a
toy how dare you
um oh we got a full look at Daniel's
Daniel Craig's scrapped Multiverse
Amanda's costume design for the role of
Boulder the brave I think can we oh wow
of course Boulder the brave is the was
the father of Odin in Norse mythology I
think he's another child of uh Odin okay
I believe so this could have been could
be Iran Chrissy Am I Wrong uh this would
have been like it wake up an eight two
eight four yeah yeah because like it you
know so much of well of uh Thor and Odin
and Asgard in the comics is taken
directly from uh Norse mythologies a lot
of it has changed but there are elements
that are there uh but I believe ball did
the brief was another or he's involved
in Ragnarok in some aspect as well he
does something in the series of events
of things that must happen yeah I think
there was an Easter egg in Ragnarok of
like one of the statues was involved
right right so they would have had kind
of like krasinski's uh Reed Richards
they would have had yeah some people on
the channel saying brother of Thor so
yeah I think he was another son do you
guys think when they scrapped that
costume they threw it in one of the many
dumps in
New Jersey
are you calling New Jersey a dump okay
the entire State yes aren't you from New
Jersey I'm from New York oh sorry
concrete jungles where dreams are made
of just seven hours Northwest
right by Niagara Falls the old concrete
jungle of Rochester
speaking of Multiverse Madness another
headline uh Multiverse Madness writer
Michael Waldron is going to be writing
Secret Wars It's been made official
clearly the folks at Marvel enjoyed his
work Multiverse Madness they want to
give him one of the big upcoming tent
polls in uh the upcoming phases
um insiders say meetings for the job
took place last month while a number of
writers met many believe Waldron was the
front runner given how much trust the
studio has in him and uh though the film
will not be directed by Destin Daniel
[ __ ]
right because he's directing okay
movie does not have
a director so there's still a chance for
Brandon
I could I could submit I could make a
few tweaks probably go to Steven
Spielberg
bad Bunny's movie there's a lot of
jersey jerseys jerseys I can't believe
they all have Wi-Fi I was told that
state didn't have Wi-Fi connection I'm
so sorry
you know what Chad the only way you can
truly get revenge on Tommy is by
donating enough money to make him dance
that is true hey I already worked out
this morning okay no I didn't it's crazy
that they they are giving Waldron this
movement uh he most recently uh wrote
Multiverse and Madness was one of the
writers on that movie uh and he from
started out on Loki right Loki season
one of the staff writers and locusts
yeah so also created the star series
heels if you're a fan of that I don't
watch uh but yeah yeah Michael Waldron
what's him I believe yeah holy smokes
given how much he you know helped Define
the Multiverse in the MCU and this is
the Multiverse system it's kind of like
bringing it all uh together again uh I
like the idea that he's probably
presented a good plan and they like it
yeah the internet's really awesome about
what about Walter and Ryan Seger award
why is that I don't know I like for the
internet
I think people are decided some some not
everybody just some people are
dissatisfied with Multiverse and Madness
is writing and I I think I enjoyed
Multiverse Madness because of Sam Raimi
like it's it's Evil Dead it was evil
dead for children and I loved it but um
I didn't I was like I didn't have that
much of a beef with it I'm not too
nervous about Michael Waldron taking on
secret and you know the the Marvel
machine is a very specific thing being
not only being a good artist but a good
artist that can Thrive within that
machine takes a certain kind of person
right like the russos and Marcus mcfeely
and people that have like had a lot of
success in Marvel so clearly he must be
just of that stripe right we're like if
I get trusts him yeah maybe the oh there
was a lot going on in Multiverse Madness
director changes and rewrites and stuff
like that so we don't we'll never know
what his strength looked exactly like
um a lot of people are throwing 609 for
Trenton area code at me is 609 the last
time it's safe to go outside in Trenton
before the trash goblins oh my God oh my
gosh call the Jersey people trash
goblins oh or the people that hunt the
Jersey people I'm told they don't have
much good meat on their bones because
they're so rotten God damn what who hurt
you I know there's someone who
secret kingdoms hidden in uh amongst the
regular ones I uh there we are going to
talk about Black Panther were kind of
forever today of course and Dr Doom's
involvement because it was a really
interesting article in The Hollywood
Reporter uh in their heat vision section
which is kind of like their editorials
area uh it was written by Richard Ruby
newbie apologies I typed his name wrong
oh God uh Richard Ruby was Jack Ruby's
oh hell yeah nepotism is real
it's real I love Dragon City clubs but
we're trying to give them a shot
Richard Newby apologies uh he did a good
job kind of connecting these dots from
interviews recently about who the real
villain in Black Panther wakanda forever
could be who is it uh well I mean he
brings up the fact that you know
Heritage has been out there saying like
Neymar's not the villain Neymar has his
own agendas and stuff uh and he also
brings up this kind of interesting part
in the trailer that umbaku means kind of
talking about cuckoo Clan and he's like
oh this is like their God and their if
you destroy him what is that going to do
to the people and it's a really an
interesting analogy for what's going on
in wakanda right they've lost their King
they've lost their God you know their
representative of their Avatar of a God
and so now they're in chaos and I think
like in baka's point is like if your
plans to kill Neymar you're just going
to create the same problem for them
you're living through that right now so
what does that mean and it's just we
we've been talking around the office
like this trailer was great it's awesome
a lot of the same shots and like kind of
same stuff we've already seen maybe new
parts of it but it does seem like the
Marvel loves to hold back on my third
act review especially for this movie
right there's a lot we haven't seen it's
a three hour long movie and there's a
ton we haven't seen well even so in in
the of course the thumbnail of this
video and the speculation in this
article and what we're going to
speculate on is that Dr Doom is the
actual villain and that's the case that
like uh Richard's making in his article
is that like Doom makes a lot of sense
here he's a long time and the comic's
been involved with both Namor and
t'challa and the fact that this movie
probably originally started you know
when they were thinking of a sequel uh
and you know Chad MC Chadwick Boseman
was still around to do it it was going
to probably be named or yes but like
Neymar and t'challa's conflict now that
we can't have that is like do you use
Neymar as a foil not as like an enemy
but as a foil and showing how it would
have gone kind of uh with with uh still
there look how many people I'm sorry
just this is correct me 880 people voted
on the Deadpool normally where we
average around like five votes no that's
not true a couple hundred but surprising
in the 40 saying Deadpool 3 could be
better than endgame wow
he said no no but that no 53 said in
I don't think
having Doom come in this movie would be
great as like kind of a third act
villain but yeah how do we get to Doom
right is that has that very always been
around and we just no one's mentioned it
because it's not important we know we're
going to the U.N or something that looks
like the U.N right there'll be people
over there from France and in the US and
China and Germany and all these other
countries wouldn't it be real easy to
have somebody sitting there with lack
area under their ticket yeah sure we've
never heard about latvary I mentioned
have we heard about Serbia have we heard
about
um Bahrain yeah where's Bahrain uh
Equatorial Guinea there's lots of actual
real world countries that haven't yet
been mentioned yeah to you right come on
the break room and show us where Bahrain
is on the map where's Denmark you
cowards yeah mads Mickelson's uh
Hometown
um I I like that idea I also think like
um there's a great quote in this most
recent trailer right it's a uh it's
Neymar saying right the most broken
people make the best leaders right but
that something like someone who's
already a leader and broken would say
right right yeah I think I'm pretty
chill right and that's why Oprah
believes in the secret because she's
successful she's manifested it but is
there a more broken leader than Dr Doom
could you imagine Oprah going to sleep
every night dreaming of a bike
that's the first tenant of the secret
uh
desire and you manifest specifically a
bike or yeah well that the secret
documentary that's the first like
analogy they make it's like a little boy
wanted a bike and he went to bed and he
dreamed of it every day and sure enough
he got that bike and you're getting a
bike and you're getting a bike and
you're getting a bike you're all getting
bikes I love bread that's my Oprah
impression let's keep going remember she
did those commercials I love bread if
you haven't seen Tommy's SNL really yeah
it's all over us it's great stuff it's
called nohopra
Dr Doom is a Broken Man I mean his mom
is like literally stuck in hell oh right
he tries to go get her once with Dr
Strange my mom got stuck in hell once
New Jersey for a weekend oh my gosh uh
the turnpike the good people of I know
we have a lot of East Coast amazing
Kevin Smith is from New Jersey Kevin
Smith okay you're not winning me oh my
God it's the good people of East
Rutherford Bon Jovi one of the worst
people on Earth
from New Jersey
I want to upset the monsters in the chat
Beyonce is from Houston yeah
um but if if like we were saying yes a
lot of great people come from Washington
State Kurt Cobain
um uh where did that get him uh okay
I'm just trying to be happy
um but uh Dr Doom uh right like I think
Brandon you were talking about we know
vibranium is going to be a weird part
right yeah hell yeah right and you
pointed out there's a lot of different
in the comics there's different
vibranium and and the only it's not just
from wakanda the only deposit right so
it could be interlocan where Neymar's
folks are from maybe there's also
deposit yeah it's infamously in
Antarctica uh uh
in like the Savage land and stuff like
that there's like a hidden deposit of
vibrating which creates this whole weird
land uh that would be very cool to see
we saw at d23 and it's been talked about
a lot like this clip of like soldiers
trying to break into this vibranium lab
in Mali and then like Queen ramonda and
like the rest of the drama will actually
like March them in we I don't think we
really know which army it was I think
Eric uh was saying it was like the
French's Army I don't know if you could
see the patches or not I don't recall
but it would be great if like America
you know that happens at that um media
America's like that wasn't us and
friends like that was us and from the
back you're here like it was us and it's
like librarian yeah
Edward K Ross oh okay I mean the Everett
K Ross reveal of uh as Dr Doom is the
like Darth jar jar bigs of yes of the
MCU how would any of his actions in the
first film make sense it doesn't matter
okay he's learning the technology he
gets to go into their lab he gets to
play with one of their virtual reality
killmonger maybe he doesn't want to kill
myself he doesn't like killmonger taking
over the most technology technologically
advanced country in the world coming for
Liberia no I mean that that that we're
gonna get back later we're gonna talk
about how Doom could be introduced who
could be playing Doom
um what types of Dr Dooms we could see
what about Justin Bieber is dude
Canadian Justin Bieber we had some
Canadians in the Super Chat I love our
friends from Canada they're America's
Duke who are the people in the chat that
you don't like from they're from New
Jersey I think Ohio a Twist of this
whole thing though could be right is it
turns out that name was not the main
villain of the film but it also turns
out that like a Doctor Doom uh and
Liberia is that the main villain of the
film but by the end of the film these
three countries align with each other
and doom becomes like an ally uh for
wakanda and tolocan and it's kind of
like now the rest of the world has to
deal with these three super powers that
are like we're tired of being pushed
around being in secret we're out in the
open our fish people are going to shop
at your Walmart and you're gonna have to
get used to it and now we're gonna put
the plastic straws on the land take that
I don't know about that land turtles
they go back we're switching the turtles
the sea turtles go to the land the land
turtles go to the toads are frogs frogs
yeah submarines are buses buses or
submarines none of this will work but I
I think I don't like that there only
because Dr Doom one of the all-time
great villains yeah to make him some
kind of like uh I think he's also you
get the potential there to have him be
like a True Villain not like an
anti-hero or whatever maybe there's a
logic maybe they flesh him out he does
have a great backstory and multiple
backstories in the comics but like he
wanted to be bad right I wanted to be
bad I also want him to be a 12 year old
boy what I want child victim
I want young Doom hello Mr Neymar my
name's Victor vondo no you sound like a
news I'm selling ice cream cones for
vibranium I hope I have these Fantastic
Four people don't nuts up this space
journey I'm going on oh geez Mister uh I
just got doomed in my pants
[Music]
okay got a good on you he's a child from
the 30s yeah
yesterday he was the old man taking the
phone calls no that was Victor I was in
characters Victor Von Doom Jessica it's
called yes and not no because there is
also the there's a a time in the comics
when Doom thinks he's a king uh or he he
hopes he stands that he's a king he's
like I'm Victor Von Doom and I'm the
most powerful evil magician ruler in the
world I must be a king and I think Kang
was basically you're not a king stop
being so thirsty but that could be a fun
twist we don't know who the 616 is Kang
is maybe he's not born yet uh because
most kings are from the future but like
if it is Victor Von Doom kind of like is
a Kang it is true do you think Jonathan
Majors is playing Victor Von Doom oh
that would be a fun little twist but it
seems like they're using it for too many
villages already he's already got a full
dance card what we're gonna say to us
again nothing I hit myself with a
microphone oh okay fair great thankfully
now I'm the ridiculous one okay
um throw in the chat uh we're gonna come
back to Doom uh throwing your chat a
likelihood he's the True Villain of
wakanda forever does he even show up
because there's also a chance he shows
up but it's a post-credit scene it's
just a little Cameo setting up you know
his appearance in Fantastic Four or
something like that it's kind of a
passing appearance or do you think he is
truly so like are you saying the most
likely odds are either it is the early
conflict of the film are wakandans
versus tolokans uh to lotions
is lotion
[Applause]
hydrated
um but I like if the Earth is is
wakandas versus to lotions but it's
somehow it's it's sparked by something
Doom is doing he's kind of puppet
mastering the conflict to set them
against each other or it's to lotions
versus wakandans and he swoops in as
like oh what kind of I'll help you
against these water people but then he
backstabs them and like you know
something you can call him that uh yeah
you're calling Ocean City people in the
City New Jersey oh there's another one
uh jabuzi Dyke asks do you think it's
possible killmonger was a spy of Doom
and he used his Heritage to get
killmonger as leader of wakanda that
would be an interesting thing if like
some behind the scenes uh killmonger's
money whoever was like funding his
operations right uh was Victor Von Doom
and was kind of like stress testing
wakanda to see like can I get a plant in
there can I find out what's going on on
the inside maybe killmonger wasn't even
aware right like who was fun yeah or
something like that right yeah oh that's
interesting I like that
um uh we've got a couple other super
chats we'll talk about or do you see any
other
um what's what's Rupert Jamison saying
there Deadpool 3 will be as big as trash
King TB
now you're a trash King not a
trash bag that's a different kind of
King yesterday oh I'm uh King uh Bucky
Barnes ATL sand just jumped on and what
the hell is happening you and me both my
man
you and me both put it to you this way
we've been talking from our New York to
our New Jersey oh no which part is the
New Jersey oh no it's the hole oh no
okay moving on
moving on should we be uh uh talking
about how to get energized yes uh energy
is that somebody referenced in the chat
uh Mr Poopy butthole you know uh we're
Mr Poopy butthole might be featured
right here on the collector's box G fuel
for Rick and Morty the collectors box is
really cool it's got pickle Rick Mr
meeseeks Mr Poopy butthole Beth all the
all your favorite characters are on here
okay if you nabbed one of these
collector boxes you'll never have to
work another day in your life that's
right is that true you can live off of
the dividends of this bag I heard
they're going on Cree Bay for up to
upwards of nine they're on stock z for
sale for thousands of dollars Green Bay
Green Bay yeah it's a cream-based eBay
it's the eBay for creams cream day and
they say creepy
but those creams aren't for eating guys
those screams are for spreading all over
your hide
uh Tommy's always keeping it creamy here
um but uh this is one of the many
flavors for my screamy to my cream
that's right from your Mr meeseeks to
your Mr Poopy button yeah okay all right
do you feel sorry about that guys
[Music]
all right but all right this is the Rick
and Morty uh flavor uh unstable portal
fluid I'm actually drinking it right now
my Rick and Morty Shaker is really good
it is it is really nice it's like kind
of a Tangy uh lemonade kind of vibe it's
very tasty now this is an energy formula
which means it's got caffeine baby
some of the G fuels I think oh combine
the flavor yeah they explode no you
can't cross streams you can't mix and
match I think that's dangerous I might
try it I don't know Tommy I don't trust
it or a Madman but they also have um
flavors on there inspired by Thor 11
Thunder Amazon's the boys Spider-Man
Venom uh you should go check those out
and there's all kinds of whatever your
flavor profile they get a lot of gaming
stuff on there too you should go to G
fuel you should use our promo code which
is
um new Rockstars it's the name of our
channel oh there it is you not only get
30 off your order but it helps us out a
lot yeah okay uh it causes uh g-fuel to
continue to work with us supported
supporting the break room helping us
bring this show to you with all of our
elaborate costumes and dance routines
yeah so
um head over to G fuel get yourself a
tub of unstable portal fluid or any
other flavor you like use our promo code
to save 30 they've got non-caffeinated
ones too they do hydration
swirl a few together I think I do want
to apologize Green Bay is actually he
works at Salt Bay's restaurant but he
puts a peppercorn cream down on the
steak because all right he does he's a
very handsome guy that creams down his
hair
a pepperon cream yeah like a peppercorn
sauce uh from our from our previous poll
half of you are thinking that Doom is
not in this movie at all which is pretty
high I like to see that I'm afraid
people are gonna get two yeah Doom hyped
on this and if there's no Doom they're
gonna be all angry it's the end credit
that's fine too then they'll be happy
again I mean this kind of does this is
like kind of the the the good and the
bad with the inner the age of the
internet and the age of speculation is
like we know these we know these movies
have come out are coming up for so long
like we know that but we knew black
panther 2 was coming out basically after
black panther one made a billion dollars
like right so it's like we start
speculating and start getting our hopes
up for these characters to show up and
then if they don't somehow we judge the
movie on that whereas it's like no the
actual move it's like a movie that's
what I like about the movie because it's
like a movie was this Harry Styles I'm
sitting next to him yeah it felt like a
movie more like scary style yes
watermelon murder
yeah
all right we've got a couple other kids
our friend uh uh free girl saying in the
chat uh no do you think Doom will show
will make his first appearance with the
mask or without definitely with this
without definitely I think he's gonna
make his appearance with the mask but
then when we get back to him maybe we'll
do the flashback yeah yeah yeah I think
the first time or we meet a character
maybe he's going by another name or
whatever right he's he's the senator or
whatever and only when he puts the mask
on do you realize it was doomed the
whole time do you think there's a chance
to that maybe I think it'll be like
credits are wrong credit to Rolling
thank you oh ayatsi symbols no animals
were harmed black panther will return
and then it like cuts and then it's like
a waiting room and you hear like music
like
these people sit around you hear some
magazine Pages flip and then a nurse
leans over the counter and she's like
Doom Victor Von Doom oh he's a patient
he's not a patient being a doctor and
then have pans over and a man gets up
and he's like that's me and he has a
horribly burned face
not okay interesting interesting take on
the cannon hey um uh Courtney Scott
asking
what if Dr Doom was in sokovia at some
point that's interesting right there's a
lot of parallels between Zemo and
sokovia and doom and lavaria the Dooms
and the zemos have had dinner several
times a lot of it right before the start
of World War II they did not say good
things yeah yeah yeah Victor Von Doom
was wheeled into a hospital and the
attending nurse said Doctor this this
boy has been very badly hurt in a car
accident and unfortunately his father
was killed and the doctor said I can't
operate on this boy he's my son how is
that possible Dr Doom is a woman wake up
20 20 20 20 22.
uh would anything uh uh trigger the
Marvel internet
I mean I am I'm waiting for the day when
they kind of cross genders on a
character I think it's long overdue I've
always pushed for a swap swap uh make Mr
Fantastic to storm and to store Mr
Fantastic why give Sue storm the
stretchy stuff why his name is Mr
Fantastic it's called Miss Incredible
yeah yeah it'll be fun we're gonna make
Superman superwoman uh not on my watch
K-LOVE reactions put in the chat hey we
still don't know who Sharon was talking
to at the end of Falcon Winter Soldier
uh the power broker Sharon Carter she
was talking to the same nurse that
called Victor Von Doom she was making an
appointment at that same place and that
nurse
Jesus Christ
can be nurses open your eyes
all right you guys want to sit next week
because you did it so good no no no uh
but uh we do want to talk Tommy about uh
apologies to Andor we are going to talk
about Andover oh hell yeah uh and I know
we joke a lot we say apologize we love
vandora Unapologetic it's a really great
show I'm gonna get to work earlier than
I normally wake up tomorrow so that we
can do a Wikileaks episode that's how
much I like yeah Tommy's sleeping here
tonight yeah I usually wake up around
1pm yeah uh then they have to slap me
away for an hour to put this full face
of makeup on because it's a nightmare
under here uh you know what
enough jibber jabber yeah
it's time for mandatory fun
adorable that we play the graphic time
horrible hit it four times
let's
recap and or fantasy league of course
the winner of the indoor fantasy league
will be joining the winner of the
She-Hulk fantasy league up on our wall
of Champions don't look at it it's empty
right now as Barren as my womb uh now
last week Jessica had eight points Zach
had eight points but then presented a
pretty solid argument uh that uh that uh
Marva poisoned the child uh so that we
gave him three bonus points since I put
him to 11. Brandon had 15 points with
just a really great showing and I had 10
points not too bad zero car and that's
my boy now let's talk about this episode
that we just had episode four going in
this is the points that I awarded
Jessica via Whitney who chose uh
Lutheran for you you got 15 points for
that Dynamite cosplay I mean that
dress-up sequence was done in the mirror
with the wig that's the one time I would
have liked something from the original
put in that song uh that that lady was
singing at Jabba's Palace yeah returned
the Jedi
oh that way he's getting ready you know
getting jazzed out yeah I like it that
was fun yeah they needed some music
though uh so you got 15 for that Zach
you had Cassie and Andor I give you
eight total points five uh for taking a
nostalgic name that didn't belong to him
by Blood like Rey when she was like
Skywalker he took he took Clem right his
uh his uh allegedly his uh adopted
father step father's name yeah uh then I
gave you three points for Andor holding
his temper while he was being bullied by
those Rebels but you're right it was a
more passive episode
he kept it chill I see now why the
beginning of Rogue one he's like oh
you're another Rebel spot okay MLS beads
getting us dangerously close to another
song can't take it we'll get there if we
can now and then Brandon you had mon
mothma I gave you ten points five points
for a toxic marriage and five points for
Espionage how are the points
my rulings are final and they are fair
why did you give me when he 15. because
I like you uh
don't want to get a free Seafood
so I took my boy sterile Khan again oh
no oh no oh it's okay the song
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the jump to the left
and then it's up to the right
put your hands on your hip
bend your knees in time
[Music]
okay okay okay cut the music
so I took zero card and I gave myself
five points for running home to Mommy
and three points for General brooding
you should get like 12 yeah who's who's
worse cereal Cosmo or uh Moon Knight's
Mom oh wow so far Moon Knight seems have
done more damage I did like it was a
nice slap give me a little slap from the
neighbors also uh as Eric played out in
the breakdown of that episode she played
all three witches in the recent uh
Washington Macbeth incredible like an
incredibly physical performance anyways
you should go watch that even just for
her performance yeah um we see more of
Cheryl Kern's mom in this series yeah so
now uh this week is very simple okay we
assume that uh I almost called him
Neymar and door a little out of breath
and the rebel gang are gonna go in and
complete that heist mission of taking
the payroll from the Empire I think
that's what's happening we believe that
this is we're basing we don't have
screeners anymore this we're going in
blind
this week is simple okay you pick a
character that character dies in The
Heist okay you get 15 points wow here's
your choices and if you want to pick
another character that I didn't name
you can you can you can insert them we
got Charis nemec who's the kid who's
like well I think we should give him a
chance he was sleeping on the job
sleeping on the job yes we've got arval
who is Richie from the bear cousin
cousin some cocaine out the back of this
pants pants
we got syntha Caz uh that's the
non-blond doctor woman yes uh that's my
favorite CBS procedural drama
coming up after F boy blasters they're
from space but they get around
David Duchovny and Timothy shalloway are
F boy blasters The Twist they're the
same person from different times
we jump through different times
and then the last uh person we have is
Gorn the Empire turncoat yeah uh Empire
turn code on HBO this summer uh so yeah
let's roll let's roll right
as the commissioner also I represent the
chat by the way if we win I'm sending
someone from the chat a victory meal as
well oh if we win
find it Captain D's Seafood nearest
okay well here's my logic so kyris nemic
who's a little kid or not he's not a
little kid but he's the younger the guy
kind of the mousy presence I think it
feels a little sketchy that guy just has
a sketchy Vibe it could be a double
agent there
um but I do think he has the best chance
of dying maybe he falls behind he's
gonna screw up somehow maybe gets
emotional somehow sells out the whole
group we know this Heist is not going to
go according to plan I think he might be
the cause of that he's my pick okay okay
um I'm gonna go with Gorn oh that's a
good one good okay I want a Gorn he's
good he's good he listed the names and
you you tweet I did I did I have a towel
I have a towel yeah uh I gotta go I
gotta go with cuz you know because our
Bell I think he's he's I think he'll
sacrifice himself because he seems like
the hardest one that's like you guys
don't have it in you it's definitely
most skeptical of indoor I think he'll
put himself on the line to get like
someone out of there yeah all right and
Tommy I would do anything for Santa
Claus the numb blood doctor woman
all right I'll take her
now and he won't do that time for
mandatory fun to really begin
thanks sin it's a double down
because this is the mandrel fund inside
the Mando fund that's right it's time
moving slower in this Mando every minute
in this mandatory fund is 37 minutes in
the real world wow wow and I got places
to beat it
hit the graphic again
I didn't like that at all all right it's
mandatory it's fun the segment's so
Twisted that you know we love our
Graphics so much that we kissed it
oh my gosh yes all right wow
now with speculation running rampant
there will be another villain in Black
Panther wakanda forever all seems
doomed oh Doctor Doom that is oh it's
Victor or Victoria is going to show up I
want to hear how I'm going to give you
guys a possible occupation or lifestyle
and I want you to reveal how Dr Doom
will emerge in the MCU as I want you to
pitch me on how we introduce him so
first of all like a billionaire kind of
like seems like a villain already but is
super rich public facing profile like an
Elon Musk type oh so going instead of
maybe the leader of a country he's like
more of the league
you know it's like uh you know it's Doom
core which is a little on the nose
they vary a little bit in Scent right
I'll never tell
let's put it this way it's a runner and
he has a shower oh God all right oh
Steve LaFontaine Prefontaine oh
boy I I like this as a concept
especially like we've had a lot of Rich
Tech entrepreneurs in the MCU Tony star
Justin Hammer
um uh who's who's uh um the guy that
blew up in Iron Man three uh
uh it's Killian right
right super rich I think Elon Musk from
Iron Man 2 right well however Rich Todd
is on She-Hulk oh that's right he could
have some money he's true he seems like
he's that's true he's got a little money
he's like there's kind of a void right
there is pretty rich right but he's in
capacity yeah and he's also like that's
a hereditary money right like he's not
necessary old money he's no new vote
Rich
um so like that's not very liquid right
it could be interesting to be like he's
still from that very uh maybe he still
has some you know some political power
there I like that as a Twist and so
maybe he is doing something industrial
with vibranium right like whether that's
manufacturing it maybe he's like uh
maybe he's got a synthetic vibranium
that's almost as good as the real thing
or something like that that could be
interesting tasty I like that like a Dr
Michael morbius inventing Blue Blood by
brandium by blandium um what is generic
vibranium whatever time it is where
you're at it's always morbid time well
it's actually literally mandatory fun
time so why don't we take that mug and
throw it in the trash with the rest of
your jersey now how could we see Dr Doom
being emerged as a shield or sword
scientist or perhaps a Hydra scientist
oh
I would like to say you could have a
thing where if they make a little
twister Rooney and have somehow Zola be
involved with doom like Zola creates
Doom in some sort of way because we know
Zola is still out there in the algorithm
somewhere if Zola is able to identify a
person and maybe like Doom wasn't born
bad he was turned and Zola is able to
like turn a scientist or a Hydra or you
know turn a sword scientist or something
whose name is Victor Von Doom is from
Liberia but isn't evil but Zola knows
that he has the potential to be because
of his connections and whatever and
maybe Zola sets off the experiment that
creates Doom like Doom doesn't go to
space it happens here on Earth that's
very interesting I think in both that
scenario and the billionaire like you
know in my scenario I do think that that
makes me think Doom not a big part of
this movie only because this is so much
like maybe that's like that's the
background story if it's more of a cameo
or just an introduction only because
this movie seems to be so much about
being a leader of a
right and so it's like any scenario in
which Doom is not the leader of Liberia
it feels like it doesn't belong in this
as a big part of the plot of this movie
because it's like you know like Panther
leads wakanda Neymar leads to locan what
if he's like the vice president Liberia
has a president and the vice president
please doctor Victor's father's name
they call me Vic and then we just know
that that President's gonna go dick Doom
is a great name for a porn star uh what
about an alien I hate that what about an
alien could it could he be an alien
coming down Crashing Down to Earth no no
all right we'll scrap that one how about
a
[Laughter]
foreignly Charming you know like where
he's just like a lot of various happy to
help guys whatever you need I mean the
reveal of Victor Von Doom is actually a
scroll who wanted to like we're going
back to life area okay yeah yeah and
they but then he's like a foreign
Diplomat also okay too much diplomatic
immunity it's been revoked uh all right
finally this is what I'm picturing
a like International Playboy celebrity
you know like like a like a Formula One
driver like he he is like a lavarian
Olympian or something like that like
he's he's a like oh his power comes not
from the government but being like a
hero but he's an influencer almost like
he's like he would appear on Dancing
With the Stars in the MCU which is
probably Canon he's the king of
vladberry and so you think this is
mostly a doom that does not wear the
mask well right now I'm saying like this
Doom is still evil but he's no he's not
uh he doesn't have his full Doom uh
Powers yet but he has the the uh
malevolent intentions
again now do you think we meet him as
Victor Von Doom and we in the audience
all know that yeah
I think so I think it's like you know
the way kind of like uh I feel like
early 2000s movies were like that where
they were like this character is the
name you know they're gonna end up bad
but we're just gonna let you watch you
have you get to experience the journey
from you know back to right exactly yeah
Victor Von Doom Formula One driver or
Victor Von Doom Olympic you know
whatever track athlete or wrestler or
power lifter or whatever Chief Doctor
Doom
I do like that as an idea right and like
so you think he's like weighing in on
the conflict I think he's just an
influencer so he's like like you know
it's almost like a like a Dan Bilzerian
I hate to say but it's like not with
that but you know what I mean like where
it's like his his presence is basically
he's Mr Beast he's just online he's Mr
Beast
and like he just happens to be in
wakanda when all this stuff is going on
because he's doing like a video or
something what do you think Jessica
um
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll take that as total agreement uh
what I had to say uh this concludes
mandatory fun uh we've got a couple good
uh Super Chat folks uh Bucky Barnes atlc
my man we did uh maybe there might be
it'd be hard to squeeze in one more time
more uh MLS beads uh zaddy that's a
great outfit for Superman I don't know
what you're talking about it's a
terrible outfit for Superman it's a
great outfit for Clark that's right
uh Hugo Z how about chimichangas for the
draft meal oh if you win I'll send some
Jimmy John's Seafood chimichangas oh
does that exist I'll eat it somewhere
out there uh also MLS beats in great
costume themed uh a day for the break
room thank you
um there might be more of these in store
for you in October we're having a lot of
fun with Halloween October yeah what
makes Halloween heads here so you never
know what we're going to dress up as
um my doctor said I actually do have a
big Halloween head and that's the
problem yeah it's too big medically my
head is called
it's a Wire magazine Wire magazine
called my head no no no no no no no
oh my God
uh okay here uh Rupert James and Zan uh
vandu builds Multiverse traversing Tech
we end up at Battle World Secret Wars
and ASM gets an alien suit Oh Amazing
Spider-Man oh very interesting I mean
that certainly feels like a big Arc for
Doom like over the next uh two phases
yeah of Marvel films yeah I I think like
doom and King working in conjunction in
a weird way might be interesting
if Kang like uses Doom to be like hey I
can give you all this if you help me if
you help this King win one thing so far
in the MCU right Kang does not have an
army Kang himself is a very powerful guy
I guess it's like if the six one six is
Ken why is he who remains or if there's
another Kang I don't know yeah but in
all the comic book iterations Dr Jim
commands an army said I'm just a robot
sometimes they're just the Liberian army
or whatever right but like so maybe he
needs some boots on the ground oh no
Brady Thomas
you're getting way too close you know
what the the that is very thank you for
you guys are great I ain't rounded up
today I didn't stretch
oh God never mind
the beads
this is
are we going out on this
he's got to scroll back
John's gotta scroll back
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just a jump to the left
[Music]
put your hands on your hips
underneath time
again
thanks for watching
[Music]